hi everybody we're the cast of critical
role
and this is the wired autocomplete
interview
[Music]
me first yeah Laura you're at first
rip away all right here we go
who does Laura Bailey voice in Naruto oh
that's a good question
we're out to the races I know we no I
know my voice is Mom Mom that's how she
sounds Naruto salmon did it come in Sam
and I have both written and director for
that show and I don't know the answer
either
where does Laura Bailey get her dice I
get my Dice from all over conventions
gifting
Etsy I get my Dice from the critical
role store obviously thanks Sam good how
did Lord Bailey Travis Willingham meet
when we were extras right background we
were background extras on this like
random internet show I don't even know
what it was 1999 oh my gosh we had to
sit at a table for like 12 hours and we
weren't allowed to actually talk we just
stared at each other and fake talked his
love at first watermelon watermelon
watermelon I can see him being Charming
if he never had to like actually say
anything did Laura Bailey sing daughter
of the sea I did sing daughter of the
sea that was for World of Warcraft
that's the one is Laura Bailey
left-handed am I the only left handies
in the cast I think so I think so wow
yeah and all of a lot of my characters
in video games I make them left-handed
as well oh really yeah there we are
all right I only get four
who does Travis Willingham voice
myself
Heroes villains animals that talk with
white gloves oh I I voiced Thor Odin's
son for about 10 plus years for Marvel
what does Travis
willingham's tattoo mean right
right Elder futhark like Viking runes I
always said that if I was lucky enough
to Play Thor for 10 years I would get a
Thor tattoo and instead of getting like
a hammer or a winged Helmet or something
Worthy is a big thing in Thor's Canon so
I got something that represents worthy
and now everybody that watches this some
scholar is going to be like that's not
what that says you dumb yes that
says pepperoni pizza and our son Ronan
will be thrilled
yeah why is Travis Willingham
actually that's a question for the group
why why am I in that position I was
pretty smart yeah you're our fearless
leader someone said we we need to open a
bank account yeah
I wouldn't know the meters one three
stones I'm I'm six foot four inches tall
whoa wow in bare feet in shoes much
higher depending on the designer send me
your stuff check that boat
that was good to do it yeah who does
Matthew Mercer voice and Vox Machina
oddly myself a couple times I also voice
Silas Briarwood in season one I'm Brazil
The Hope Devourer in season two and uh
orthax the Shadow Demon in season one as
well and trinket and Craven it's all
over what makes not Mercer tick a good
gym uh a good gym
knowing the rules is fine but that that
can be flexible doing in a preparation
where you're comfortable but also being
willing to let it go based on what the
players are feeling and just listening
to them you're not listening to your
players you're not really collaborating
and creating something special
[Laughter]
it's the hair you got to have amazing
hair to be a good GM
10 years of this
uh where does Matt Mercer get his minis
at miniature Market's a great website
you can go to there's Troll and Toad
which is fantastic you do like the train
mini place too like the little hobby
minis oh yeah get a lot of cool like
miniature train stuff train stores are
great how does Matt mercer deal with
these people come up come up with names
it is it just chooses a body part and
changes one letter
Enis mangina
there you have it folks say them out
loud multiple times before you say it to
your players because they will make you
suffer for years to come if you don't
Matthew Mercer vest
I have a few they flow nice I call them
my my modern Mage look because it just
has kind of a little bit of a weird
different glare and you can get them you
get them online pretty pretty cheap
anyway
how did Marisha Ray
and Matt Mercer meets oh
a sketch comedy show that was supposed
to be a nerdy Saturday Night Live for
the internet for the internet and we had
one writer's room meeting and then
that's where that show ended nothing
came of that as many shows in Los
Angeles oh one thing came from that the
only thing that came from that is is me
and him how did
Matt Mercer proposed to Marisha Ray oh
boy I love all your all your questions
I'm just failing failing the Bechtel
test
he built a whole ass escape room that
was very like lovecraftian kala cthulhui
themed and there were a bunch of
cultists in robes and Travis Willingham
was a tentacle monster
that I had to stab in the heart with a
glowing dagger and no one died but it
was close
there was supposed to be a blade switch
that happened from a real sharp pointy
thing to one that was not so much and
somebody ended up shouting with like
wrong
I was in a silicone like mask and I
heard wrong knife and I was like what
is Marisha Ray's think of Matt Mercer
what does Mercer Ray's new character I'm
assuming they mean in campaign three
sorcerer warlock multi-class named ladna
just a little joyful Undead kind of
manic pixie dream girl is Marisha Ray
vegan that's a top search do I give off
vegan well you do have red hair she's
been publicly talking about Taco Bell
for the entire time Taco Bell's vegan uh
no I am not vegan and yes I will be
reevaluating what vibe I put out that
that is a top asked question Marisha Ray
Creator Clash
yeah I fought in Creator Clash this year
2023 which is like a big internet
Creator boxing event for charity I
fought Haley sharp and lost but I went
all five rounds so it was great boxing's
awesome
[Applause]
who does Sam Regal work for who does Sam
Regal voice you grew up watching me play
Donatello in the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles 20 years ago oh no you don't
ever say the times
I also play Phoenix Wright from time
that's his name right yeah yeah
I had a panic that it was some something
else so uh Phoenix Wright Ace Attorney
from time to time I've done other stuff
too I've played Spider-Man Scanlon short
home in the legend of box Teddy oh yeah
Teddy Anderson that's a cute one what
did Sam Reid go win an Emmy for oh oh
well I'm very talented so so it could
have been for a lot of things yeah the
writing the acting the direction but
what was it for just to torment us with
yeah I won for a great show for uh Prime
video called danger and eggs I was the
voice director of a show and I went for
best directing where does Sam Regal get
his shirts
I make these shirts I typically order
them from really cheap places and
they're really really bad they fall
apart they smell like vinegar how often
do you get a rash from them daily R Sam
Regal and Liam O'Brien dating
for many many years
happier no we are both married to women
currently if we were both uh single you
know who knows who knows but for now we
are just uh in love as friends why did
Sam Regal wear that damn shirt leave
critical role
[Laughter]
I got cast on Abbott Elementary and I'm
out sorry guys
one of my characters left the group uh
during campaign one but I would never
leave critical role until forced out
which might happen any day Allison Jaffe
how to pronounce Talis and Jaffe oh
I just moved the answer
what are some of the good
mispronunciations yeah oh uh toliason
has been fun uh Taliesin although that
is actually like the Welsh pronunciation
yes I believe it it means uh uh like
radiant brow which is also shiny
forehead which is why I have
what happened
[Laughter]
how much tape we got I've asked my
parents several times what happened uh
yeah uh oh God boarding school bad
clothing decisions
um very iffy hair dye I mean a lot of
things this question has so many layers
like yeah where is talison Jaffe I'm
assuming from
uh born and raised in Los Angeles Venice
Beach uh moved all the way to Santa
Monica Van Nuys I think I've lived in
almost every neighborhood uh in L.A
we've kind of moved around and yeah we
lived out of state a couple times a
little over a year in Tokyo which was
great I did a couple years in Colorado
and then I did a year in Texas where I
met uh the two of you I was like Wow
there are talented voice actors in Texas
Dallas and Jaffe critical role
characters well there's uh procedarella
who you can watch in the legend of Vox
Machining that you get all the all the
Deets there Molly makti Leaf who uh
makes people cry there's caduceus who is
just um who makes people smile yeah he's
just lovely and also vegan so we have
that uh makes dead people tea and now we
have a uh Ashton graymore who's just uh
randomly he's angry about everything and
has a very big hammer I'm checking
the checking's gotten weaker I'm just
saying well a voice
critical role hi I'm lame O'Brien
critical role and I'm 5'11.
and a half I'm just under you it helps
when I want to look up into his eyes oh
that's so sweet how did Sam Regal
and Liam O'Brien me oh boy well sat down
at a uh on a panel for a convention five
minutes into it we were making each
other laugh and I said and he told me he
was coming to La I had moved to LA a
year prior and I just said hey we should
be best friends are Liam O'Brien Sam
Regal married and Laura Bailey related
oh that's it we're fam we're all family
yeah y'all got big sibling energy does
Liam O'Brien
no I don't I remember bits and pieces
from studying German in high school I
did German exchange program when I was
in high school it's nice it need to be
the world's largest paper cut
does Laura bowley have a kid I do have a
kid
thank you oh I you all know the kid his
name's Ron and he's the best kid Laura
Bailey smells like farts right
Awards let's
listen uh I won the bafta that was for
Last of Us Part two and then I won a
video game award for Last of Us Part Two
as well Laura Bailey
we talked about this before I like dice
what's your fate do you have a favorite
diet do I have a favorite dice oh I have
a set of gudetama dice that I am those
are so pretty cute oh my God okay okay
we need a matching tattoo I was just
thinking about this I want to get a
feather tattoo with you we have tattoos
we got tattoos like as a group Laura
Matt and I have identical oh yeah we all
got the square one that accidentally
looks like a Gmail yeah
but made better decisions
the literal first thing someone said oh
do you like Gmail
the entire crew is loud
is Laura Bailey and The Last of Us yes I
am in The Last of Us what about the show
I
um so I did like a little Easter egg in
the actual series
Neil asked if I would go and be one of
the nurses in the scene in the final
scene because I played one of the nurses
in the game along with Liam O'Brien
so she got me folks beautiful
I'm sorry sorry we are gonna ruin your
whole set did Travis Willingham play
football
I did I played in high school for a few
years I walked on at TCU got hit by
people that were finally my size and I
was like I don't like this very much so
I'm gonna go act instead is Travis
William allergic
you guys I'm so allergic to cats if you
showed me a picture on your phone I'd
start having a reaction I could walk
into a house and if there are cats
present but not visible I will know
within half a minute no problem does
Travis Willingham do woodworking him
I was in the Webelos like the Boy Scouts
for I don't know one year and in the
back of the catalog they always had like
the cool like go-kart kit or the
hovercraft and they had like a Swiss
army knife and I was like I want to take
up whittling and so I got a piece of
wood and I cut myself
I was like I'm done with a league
did Travis Willingham make the Airship I
did it's like little balsa wood with
laser cutouts and stuff and it takes a
minute it took a long time it didn't
take as much as your stupid horse that
totally works yeah I made the little
ship and Robbie uh totally uh left it at
the set yeah
the kid in game
does Travis Willingham speak Japanese
hi
no basic stuff yes no I'm sorry okay
okay
another beer please if you dub enough
anime you absorb some of it a little bit
or drink in Japan yeah how does Matthew
Mercer
organize his notes Microsoft Word
and printouts like people people swear
by the laptop and that's probably a much
smarter way but I'm a very tactile
person I need to have printed sheets so
I can look like a complete imbecile
trying to figure out where I put the
right thing you find the like characters
so quickly though if we ask you
questions about something you're like oh
and then you know I lay them out in the
back there so I'd like have like uh City
information over here I had like
Regional information I have like you
know all my notes for the actual session
on the back of the the screen and then I
have other ancillary things nearby and
then my phone if I absolutely need
something that I don't have so that's
how I organize them is Matthew Mercer in
Zelda oh boy I am I'm I'm very uh
honored to voice uh Ganondorf in the
tears of the Kingdom that just came out
does Matthew Mercer
write his own campaigns I do it would be
so much easier if I didn't it's it's the
thing I love it's a thing I've always
loved since high school and so I I make
this for my friends I make this for us
to enjoy together and it's it's my hobby
time I get to sit and create stories and
and then have them destroy them in
wonderfully complicated ways when did
Matt Mercer start playing ttrpgs uh it
would have been
96 or 97. it was it was my my very
beginning of my high school I found out
later on my grandma played it uh my
dad's side really yeah my granny she
played them for a bit back back when
they first came out is Matthew Mercer
Elementary
[Applause]
is Marisha Ray
Singh can Marissa racing this is not my
forte objection you're good you just
don't have confidence I don't have
confidence in my singing I have to have
like at least two cocktails before I
sing at karaoke and when she does she
doesn't mean rendition to the Crazy
Little Thing Called Love the more common
for you for Eddie Murphy
Marisha Ray anime voices oh boy oh this
is so Laura or Sade in in in
um I don't know what's the name of that
damn thing yeah she's gone away she's
gone somewhere
I'm in some I'm in some animes
[Laughter]
tattoo meaning oh hang on hang on I can
blast through this really quick
hang on this was my first tattoo kind of
a burning man tattoo it means the line
is long but
what kind of a burning man tattoo this
was our camp art car called The
sensatron this is D and D tattoo these
are the death saving throw dots
meaningful and practical uh this is
because I love Gmail
this is a Hollywood Boulevard star
because for three years I was a Street
character on Hollywood Boulevard to make
ends meet when I first moved to Los
Angeles and then this is my lemonade
stand that I had growing up and then my
most recent one I just got this is the
oh my sorry yeah the ashari symbol yeah
it looks beautiful so thanks guys
and finally
dog oh
easy
Matt and I have a wonderful Corgi named
Omar yeah I love him so much yeah
was Sam Regal
on Broadway
I love this show
let's get to talk about myself I was on
Broadway yes I did the national tour of
Les Miserables and then I did the
Broadway production of uh The Sound of
Music and I was
very good
that was right before the junior Rodeo
yes yes I also did some Off-Broadway
Productions I was in I can get it for
you wholesale oh boy and they didn't ask
about Off-Broadway I know but I want to
go down my whole resume
theater
theater sing more than these folks
probably prefer I was in an acapella
group even before the acapella group in
college in high school I was in a
doo-wop group I sang 50s and 60s wow
wasn't there a boys band I was also in a
boy band called City boys with a z
one
I think we recorded an EP or a single uh
is that on cassette it probably is are
you guys like posted up in front of a
brick wall for sure we wore a z Cavalry
cheese
and we danced and we sang at Paramus
Park shopping mall in New Jersey oh I
did not know this yeah Sam Regal
ASMR no
hi hi wired it's me Sam Regal doing some
ASMR for you oh yeah
Sam Regal
Burt Reynolds
it's true we have never seen them both
in the same room before to clarify in
campaign one my character Scanlon short
halt would go in Disguise frequently and
I think the first time this happened in
our home game I was like I'm my name is
Burt Reynolds and you um
Sam Regal Dungeons and Dragons movies
there's some speculation that the d d
movie references my character fresh cut
grass because they say those words three
or four times during the movie
I not confirmed or denied I'm going to
say that yes
is Towson Jaffe his real name yes as far
as I know yes it is my real name
would be real one then like I lose my
power I've tried to summon you using
towels and it didn't work
it's really good Towson Jaffe
goth golf
yes yes
Jim Henson died and I wore black to
school and kind of never stopped
so that was kind of great yeah that was
more or less kind of the beginning of
that and then eventually I discovered
eyeliner and music it was pretty good
next one Talis and Jaffe
Immortal joke well it's not a joke it's
not a joke it's not a joke someone
noticed they couldn't uh find a birth
certificate on on record and one thing
led to another there found some ancient
uh tablets at a pretty good likeness
they just assume I've Been Everywhere
now it's like 70 true survivor of
Pompeii
uh toss and Jaffe
thank you
are you a grandfather
it's a lot of questions I don't know if
I can answer
as far as I know now my grandfather uh
was a screenwriter and a playwright a
lot of my family has worked in the
industry for actually like four
generations it looks like you're
blessing yourself yeah right there I
really stare I'm just gonna keep moving
uh but yeah he uh he wrote the film
adaptation of bus stop he wrote The
Seven Year Itch he wrote a um a whole
bunch of films he did the adaptation The
Manchurian Candidate it's a lot of fun
and a movie that called he uh Lord love
a duck which no one's seen but you
should it's a lot of fun Talus and Jaffe
hair I do have hair
I've been dying my hair since high
school and it's not always been this
it's been I've done like the long hair
it was bleach blonde it was jet black
I've done kind of everything and I've
kind of settled into the mohawk for the
last few years it's kind of nice Liam
O'Brien eyebrows
[Laughter]
all right
Carmen San Diego I am Carmen San Diego
no I play a professor uh Maelstrom in
the recent reboot of uh the Carmen San
Diego animated series is really good
Liam O'Brien
Bane
oh does anyone have a coffee cup for me
to speak into let's read the next
question
Liam O'Brien you were born into the time
pull out all the trees
that does not work
[Laughter]
when did critical role eyebrow eyebrows
when did critical role start technically
the home game was 10 years ago wow yeah
almost 11 2013 yeah
so many times and fail because it's so
many I think it's December of 2012.
why is critical role so popular oh I
think it's our looks I think it's
I think it's our eyebrows
yeah we're just so handsome how much of
critical role is scripted I thought that
was gonna happen
[Laughter]
everything everything before the actual
episode starts some of that's like
planned like we have advertisers and
sponsorship reads but after that after
the the intro starts it's just Matt
making it up as he goes I have no idea
what you guys are going to do that's
that's the joy of it is like keeping it
secret and letting you guys experience
it in the moment how do critical role
know each other we were all
acquaintances yeah some of us were
closer than others like I think I met
Marisha for the second time at that very
first game I didn't know Ash the first
time I met Ashley was when she came over
to play it up and I think a lot of us
have just kind of met through voice over
stuff actually go back to your previous
question I think that's why it is
popular because we're just like doing us
like we weren't cast or put together
we're just friends and well I think when
you watch you can see us enjoying it but
also it up the entire time as
well and there's just like a certain
draw to that so I think people get to
feel like they're hanging with us well
campaign to be animated oh the
answer is actually yes
Mighty nine is coming to it's been green
lit Prime video
is baking in the oven right now what is
critical role well we should have done
it started with that one
good girl is about a bunch of nerdy ass
voice actors that became really good
friends by Roland Dice and making things
up and making sure they're laughing cry
killed it nailed it who
sings critical role intro which one oh
yeah the current one is everybody yeah
everybody sings in the current intro the
last one was Laura and Ashley
yes
and the one before that was just uh
music who owns critical role we do
yeah they bought me out
that's why he's leaving is critical role
making their own system we've announced
the illuminated World System yeah and
we've announced we're making two we're
making two of our own systems we have um
a game publishing Wing called Darrington
press we made a game called till the
last gasp which was like a role-playing
dueling game and yeah midnight Queen by
midnight all these by the way are
available at our critical
shop.critroll.com what critical role
cast member are you oh
who's the bad boy I think it's Mariah
yeah that's probably the truth yeah am I
the silly one you're the prom queen the
prom queen what yeah not the class last
clown yeah it depends on the day you're
in the makeup chair longer than most of
us that's true that's true yeah yeah
Travis is the jock Williams the theater
yeah sure I'm the nerd
there's no argument I'm the nurse
Ashley's the art kid you're the
prettiest one oh
many of them are going to be gifts that
will continue to give from years to come
so thank you Google definitely some
expected ones definitely ones that will
send us into an existential crisis yeah
what happened to Charles and Jeff
I'll be thinking about that all night